um
to members of the public that are
viewing on youtube i haven't actually
had any discussions with
the
plans committee um
it was more of a german rather than part
two
i was seeking clarification
um
from another party
um
seeking some
further assistance in relation to the
situation that that week
has occurred before we went into part
two but just just to clarify where we
are so we had um the proposal to refuse
um that motion was lost and we had four
votes four and five against and the
motion to approve um was lost also
because we had four votes four and five
against so neither of those motions are
actually carried
so the situation as it remains at
present is that the application is
undetermined
so we will bring it back to a further
plans committee for plans committee to
to reconsider at a later stage
[Music]
[Music]
whenever it is it will be we'll move on
item 7c on the agenda
is um
district application and
angelo
underground and masses and present this
one
[Music]
so
wins a retrospective application for the
engineering works in relation to
improving the coastal defenses
so the location of the site is situated
within the jordanian settlement of
westwood home and situated with the
north devon aomb
the undeveloped coast
and uh surrounding the site is a mixture
of residential and commercial properties
as well as being in the flight zone
through
an
excitement
the slides before you show a site plan
detailed of the proposal
um
image from the
site please
plan before you show your cross section
of the coastal defense works
which consists of a granite rock armor
made on geotextile fabric
with the beach deposit that has been
removed and
laid up over the top of the granite
rock armor
the
elevation plan before you show a view
from beach looking southwest landmarks
this slide before you illustrate prior
to the coastal defense works and the
coastal defense works institute
on the beach
the elevation plans before you show from
the land looking north west towards the
sea
before and in situ with the granite um
what karma holders
looking from westwood home towards the
northern boroughs
slide performance shows the pedestrian
access from the slipway car park
westwood home and from the northern
burrows at the
the material planning considerations in
this case are the principal development
which provides significant benefit to
the protection of 65 properties
and 15 businesses
the
works are in
interims is an interim solution that has
a lifespan of five to ten years to
enable um a long-term solution to be
sought as outlined within the tourist
district council uh risk
this management plan
the considerations are the impact on the
landscape character and visual
which in this case is considered to
result in a minimal difference upon the
setting of the wider protected landscape
the highway safety impact his proposed
proposal is considered to result in
minimal harm and provides investment in
terms of improvement to public access
from nashville to northern valleys
ecology
during the construction works there was
damage to the
june grassland within the northern
barriers
as raised by uh natural england however
mitigation works have been conducted by
the torture council and furthermore
monitoring of the recovery has been
conditioned
uh in conclusion
provides significant social and economic
benefits to the community
of westwood home and thus
i would like to recommend improvement
with this application thank you for
listening
to the channel
thank you angelo
as members members know this has already
been
done as a matter of urgency so i'm going
to move
approval from the chair
council christie yeah i'm all in favor
of this but there's one thing which i
think really interesting i've never seen
before on page 202
202
second paragraph from the bottom
and it
it actually has a bearing on what we've
been discussing this morning the other
two applications it says there uh local
authorities can set their own net gain
thresholds this is for biodiversity but
the environment act will set a minimum
10
uh and yet this morning we were quoting
10 as those target
i found it really interesting that we
could actually quote more
for
the amazon roadside than the 10 and i
think i will bring that up next time it
comes back thank you
okay
if i just very quickly come back on that
point cancer christine um
our
currently dropped level plan which was
adopted in october 2018 was um quite
far ahead thinking and it was in front
of the environment act where it required
10 which is why we look at 10
the environment act is uh coming in now
which then sets that minimum 10
threshold so we're going the temperature
that we look at from the previous
applications was in relation to our
adopted policy which set out before the
environment that came into play
that's closely if you take the vote on
that please thank you chair council
belgium
[Music]
right we'll move on now to
the generation 7b which is the
uh
land at california lane torrington
which we asked
we deferred it to the mid-december
um for a bit more information on the car
park and you see on page two too
thanks
and as indicated by the chair this this
application was considered by you as a
committee on the 4th of november
[Music]
which you
resolve to defer it to get some more
information
the the
publishing minutes
don't
say the additional information that was
required but given the nature of the
application and also the nature of the
discussion that was had at that meeting
in the fourth of november
we have obtained an indicative surface
water drainage layout layout is
obviously before you for determination
so that has been provided and it is
appended to your agenda report um there
are no verbal updates
and as previously advised this this
application has been pulled in by
council brown to assess amenity and
overlooking
i appreciate you've already seen the
presentation once so
um
[Music]
i will i will go through it quickly
again just to remind you of the key key
elements which is a proposal um
a reserve matters proposal all matters
were reserved from the associated
outline permission for a car park so
matters of access appearance landscaping
layout and scale are before you for
determination today and this is the
submitted site location plan you can see
the skype outlines in red the
application site extends to
approximately 4.4 hectares
we have tyler's meadow
which isn't shown and it's it's
developed form actually on this plan
before you to the north great toronto
coast primary school is about 150 meters
beyond to the north up caddywell lane
this night is to the southeast great
orington approximately 600 meters from
the town centre
it's an aerial shot to indicate that the
site is currently part of an
agricultural
field there is a gate an existing gate
access which um comes out opposite
tyler's medal you can see tyler's meadow
in its complete form
um on this very photo the site is
currently subfounded by
hedgerow
um
just again to remind members of the
context of this car park proposal
the 2019 outline application for 1981
dwellings which were subsequently
allowed by an appeal inspector um almost
two years ago now um
known as the burwood site um
that approved
the matters approved that it did include
access so as you can see from this
approved plan
the access arrangements have already got
approval so whilst access is for your
consideration today in relation to the
car park the access arrangements have
already been approved by an appeal
inspector
there is a requirement also for the two
metre foot waves to be provided so that
is a condition required on that outline
just moving on this is the indicative
layout that supported the outline just
to show the context of the car park
which is before you today in terms of
the third matter and how it relates to
land that does benefit from residential
consent and how the access american
arrangements can also tie in um it's
important to know that the car park
is actually surrounded by land that does
have the benefit of the residential
commission so secondly to the south and
east of the site residential could come
forward obviously subject to the
necessary reserve matters applications
and there is a section one it's
associated with this outline we did
discuss this at the last meeting that
requires
delivery of the car park prior to the
occupation of any dwelling to be
accessed on caliwell lane
um we did discuss also the management of
the car park there are provisions in
place but through condition on the
outline for car packing carpark and also
the section 106 associate the housing
development to require management and
maintenance maintenance strategies
for
the potential for the car park to be
transferred to denver county council
or otherwise if they projected a
management arrangement to be put into
place
this is just the context and i'm aware
that it is points that was raised
at the last of the meeting on 4th of
november and again to emphasize that
because the nature of the management is
not performed today for consideration it
is the reserve matters as indicated at
the beginning of my presentation
just have um some of the photos that i i
shared with you at the last meeting so
this is kay well
cody will lane leading up towards the
school which is just behind the hedgehog
bank on the left
this is then the alternate view looking
down
the the site is beyond the hedge
immediately there
this entire is meadow number 13 and 14
and then numbers one and two um to show
the relationship of those properties
with the application site which is just
beyond the edge on the left
just a slightly closer view showing the
relationship of numbers one and two
tyler's meadow the car park slices on
the other side of the hedge and you can
see the change in the levels from the
narrow lane up to the top of that hedge
bank
now some photos within the site
um this is it's looking you can see
tyler's tyler's meadow beyond the hedge
foundry so that it's like grading change
towards that edge
but i'm just showing that topography
this is closer the proposal is for the
ground level
the ground to be leveled so that it's
it's in line with the top of the bank
which is appreciated very difficult to
see from that photo but much of what you
can see there in terms of the hedges the
planting on the top of the bank
just more distant view and appreciate
the
topography and the relationship with the
houses
now panning around so the access road
would come in
at this sort of corner point
this
is the east
and then this is just the view from the
gateway so tyler's meadow is behind and
now there's just three photos beautiful
photos that just pan around
there would be housing
wrapped around beyond the car park in
the rest of this field
so just to quickly remind members of the
proposal so his reserve matters
for all of the matters are reserved the
layout is consistent with the indicative
online plans that came before committee
in 2018 the access is also consistent
with what has been approved as part of
their word appeal
50 spaces are proposed in terms of scale
and this is consistent with the higher
officers requests and requirements and
the basis of which the appeal inspector
considers this is mitigation for the
housing development
and there is an in and out access two
points of access proposed and further
access route through to thailand's
meadow again consistent with the access
approved by the bird appeal
in terms of
the carriageway
on the whole it's
six meters there are two meter footwears
being provided and they are required by
condition as well there are no highway
objections to the access arrangement
the proximity of the car park to the
properties in thailand's meadow it
ranges between
[Music]
just over 20 meters to 35 meters
depending on the park the part of the
car park that is in closest proximity
the
there is a section at the top and that
shows it's approximately 2.5 meters from
the lane
fronting tyler's meadow up to the top of
the hedge bank you then have
the planting of the hedge and further
trees on top of that as well
next the next hand shows the proposed
landscaping
um there is a separate condition on the
outline which requires the timing of
planting and the actual details and the
detail of it but this shows
the scheme that would come forward and
it's a mix of tree planting which is the
purple trees hedgerow planting
wildflower meadow planting and grassed
areas
this would also contribute towards the
net gain which is also required through
compliance with the ecology assessment
on the outline
condition
and this is the plan that's appended to
your committee agenda report
um the outline condition condition 13
requires detail to be approved prior to
commencement and for any scheme to
comply with the flood risk assessment
and
interestingly and you know having
listened to a lot of the debate at the
meeting the fourth of november the
conditions that we have recommended now
are outlined from delhi county flood
with do require these details at reserve
matters stage i think unfortunately this
dates back to 2018 when there is that
slight disconnection in terms of the
reserve matters um
just to sort of summarize what is
proposed firstly this is
consistent with the flood risk
assessment and therefore condition 13
the
it has been confirmed both
through the flood risk assessment and
then subsequent correspondence from the
applicant that the soil has good
infiltration which has been evidenced
through soakaway tests
so there are three elements of this
drainage proposal
the first element being the improvements
to california and the
points of access and egress we'll have
conventional gullies gather surface
water runoff which will be conveyed to a
soak away within the landscaped area
which you can see rectangular soak away
highlighted on the plan
the carpark surface will be permeable
therefore water will infiltrate into the
ground
and the third element is a perimeter
french drain to inspect
localized runoff from
adjacent land
just to manage that all of that process
the
flood risk assessment indicates a
precautionary approach
in terms of the population rates so
the
calculations and blood risk
risk assessment require 28.8 square
meters of flood storage
the scheme indicatively before you
provide for 30 square meters so it needs
to slightly exceed that requirement
and
just on to the planning considerations
now
so
as indicated on the 4th of november and
in the agenda report the principle of
this is accepted there is outline
permission
um
that
is is still valid and the result of the
verb would appeal which through
sectionalistics and conditions requires
this car park or
another car park it allows for variation
so whether whether it's needed or not
it's not for consideration today in
terms of access again the the access
proposed is consistent with what has
been opposed approved for the burwood
appeal
um there are no highway objections
the layout of the scale and external
appearance
the
scale meets the requirements of the
highway officer no structures are
proposed there is a condition um on the
outline that will require details of any
barriers or any security measures um
which will be linked to the management
and times of operation the environmental
protection officers raising their
concerns in terms of amenity
and impact on residential properties
nearby the landscaping scheme includes a
variety of measures which are considered
acceptable
and in terms of other matters i i've
gone in through drainage and you now
have additional information for you
which will be confirmed by the discharge
condition 13 on the online commission
and in terms of ecology
a net gain would be secured there is a
condition on the outline which requires
compliance with a range of measures in
the ecological assessment um one of
which is specific lighting to
mitigate any harm to protected species
there is also a condition on the outline
requiring details lighting to be
confirmed
and
so that that hopefully has
reminded members of the main
considerations before you it is a
reserved matters application and the
officer recommendation is one of
approval
thank you helen thanks for that
we've got one contributor
and objection
to the application from james
shuttleworth
just put a statement in that the
planning manager will read
[Music]
[Music]
reasons to reject this application one
the school is only open for an average
of 190 days a year
two the school is not open weekend
school holidays public holidays drop off
collection about a half hour at each
time
three school street closure scheme in
borough road operating and successful at
school opening and closing times
or to access car parking allowing
vehicles to pass closure scheme twice
above opening closing times
five increasing fears about traffic
pollution on the health of children a
car park will concentrate traffic
pollution
six asking children aged four to ten to
get out of cars in a car park is unsafe
more than stepping onto a pavement
seven the junction of calibre lane at
burwood lane is to be widened to allow
beachcroft development construction
traffic past its car park later traffic
to and from these houses will pass the
club park
eight
there would be danger on a pavement from
the car park to the sport entrance
nine
two school playgrounds or about hundred
meters from any car park pollution
ten will other vehicles be allowed to
use the car park possibly blocking
access when the school is open
11. what will be the cost for
maintenance lighting security on an area
that may be sparsely used for just over
half a year
this application should be rejected on
these points raised above
particularly on issues such as pollution
and children's safety in the car park
and walking school j.a shuttleworth
thank you sean
right something for discussion
yeah
councillor christie and just a very
simple question um condition 15 on the
original
application was about are there to
produce a management maintenance scheme
can i ask who's going to pay for this in
the future
that
is yet to be known the the section 106
associated with the third appeal
requires delivery of the car park and
the options are for it to be made
available for devon county council they
have a set time period to confirm
whether they wish to take it on or not
if they don't then management
arrangements need to be put in place and
that ties in with this condition as well
so it could well go back to the people
who buy the houses
but potentially i mean that that isn't a
matter for consideration today but i i
appreciate the discussion before i
understand it's an important point for
members to understand um i don't have a
clear answer on that i think there are
provisions within a legal agreement and
now there are requirements for
management
maintenance strategy
but i you know we don't have anything
before us at this time
[Music]
in the open countryside 600 meters from
the town and 150 meters from the school
and there's been a private scheme going
and turning to a bit stopped traffic
going down to the school
which has proved very successful so it's
very unlikely
that parents will go into that
and move their children
and back backwards and forwards in that
situation the other thing is it is a far
sky area and i know the lighting is
being looked at with
even though lighting
thank you councillor brown
um
captain is on our second council
watson's approval all right thank you
well the thing is it might never be
built this car part
we discovered that afterwards
last week so it's been moved to approve
it
by council boxing setting it by council
law can we take the vote please
yes thank you chair councillor fountain
oh
that's the brown
council christie or
councillor craigy against
councillor leather
[Music]
against you kirsten
right we'll move on then item eight on
the agenda for the appeal decisions
on pages two two two two three six three
of them there
all refused
item nine um so if you just know those
please
item nine on the agenda is costs
and there are no costs
awarded
item ten on page two three seven for
their agmv applications
decisions between 19th of november last
year
and the 20th december
and then on page 238
we've got planning decisions housing 11
on the agenda
is the list of delegated planning
decisions
um
between 19th of november
and the 20th of december i'll start with
the pages
two three eight
two three nine
two four oh
two four one
two four two two four three
two four four
two four five
two four six yeah can we have an
explanation
yeah this was in relation to a tree
application damage tree and it was
partially approved limited purely to
branch removal as an immediate risk
[Music]
watching the hotel
and then the bottom of page 246 of the
refuse ones
247 yeah
right
that's the
last item on the agenda
thanks everybody for this morning thank
you for the patience of the public
and the contributors to the reason this
morning
we have that hiatus over that
road which will come back so thank you
to those who watched on youtube and your
patients
and thanks to john and kirsten